hi everyone I'm Dan to you from Khan
Academy unfortunately after about a
month and a half
Sal's unable to join us today but you do
have myself and another kind of kind of
me team member megin ppattani who's here
to kind of hold down the fort
well Sal's away and you'll be joining us
tomorrow so don't worry about that
before we get started if you have any
questions please start putting them into
the comment box and the team will
surface the questions for us to answer
and we'll do our best to do our Sal
impersonations so for those of you who
are joining us for the first time this
is just a way for us to stay connected
especially at the time at a time of
social distancing and school closures
Khan Academy is a nonprofit with the
mission to provide everyone a free
world-class education to anyone anywhere
and the way we've been doing that for
the last 10 plus years is really by
creating resources from pre-k with Khan
Academy kids through elementary school
middle school in high school covering
courses in math ela humanities sciences
and more and when this crisis hit we
recognized that it was our duty to be
even more we've created daily schedules
and learning plans to help provide
structures for remote learning we've
recorded parent and teacher webinars in
mass to provide guidance and answer
pressing questions and we've even
launched Khan Academy kids YouTube
channel with daily circle time and all
of this in an effort to keep everyone
learning through school closures I want
to remind everyone that we are a
nonprofit or funded by philanthropic
donations by folks like yourself and we
were running out of deficit before the
crisis and we've seen our surfer usages
increase two to three times what we
normally incur and what that means is we
also have increased costs and I want to
send a special shout out to several
organizations who were some of the first
to step up and help us during this
crisis so Bank of America Google org
AT&T Novartis and fastly they've all
really stepped in to help us close some
of that gap but we need more so if you
find yourself in a position to do so
please think about supporting us and if
you have any questions you can start
adding them to the message boards and
we'll try to get
through as many as we can so I'm making
we have a really great question from
YouTube from gaining runner mesh I'm
going through high school next year
I'm already worrying about work being
too much how can I keep up so I'm ready
for high school that's a great question
and first things first take a deep
breath I'm certain that you have a great
support system around you and that
remember that you're not in an alone a
lot of students are asking themselves
that question right now right you've had
a huge disruption to the end of your
middle school experience and taking on
high school is such a huge challenge in
and of itself I was a high school
teacher for nine years and I always
loved that fresh look of new students
and and how they're eager to learn and
still trying to adapt and find who they
are as they change well we fit some
great resources to help you on the
academic side of that for sure
we have learning plans for math that we
have things to help you with the content
you're looking at right now in terms of
daily schedules to help you stay on
track with what you're trying to finish
right now and then there's learning
plans for over the summer to either look
more at what you might be learning to
finish eighth grade or maybe to get you
a step ahead so maybe that content
doesn't feel as intimidating as you step
through that first door the other thing
we might be able to support you is we
have some great growth mindset content
and that might be able to help you frame
what you're learning and that experience
and how you can prepare yourself for
learning across subjects and even beyond
the academic and so I would really take
a look at both our daily schedules and
our weekly learning plans that you can
see on the screen right now to get ahead
in what you might be learning in math
come the fall yeah I would just plug the
learning plans we just hosted a parent
webinar last week on how to best utilize
it it was really for parents but it's
also you know as a student you can use
that as well it's really just a way to
add a lot of structure and to make sure
that you know the Summer Slide really
doesn't get amplified especially in a
time of school closures yeah and we have
a question on we have a question on
YouTube from junior Forester foster what
are some of your recommended books for
teenagers to read
during this quarantine I can pitch
something so right now I've been reading
Percy Jackson and the Olympians with my
niece and nephews we're on book to Sea
of Monsters it's way better than the
movies were I find it really it's really
action-packed and we also have a
recommended reading list from our Khan
Academy staff Megan do you have a
recommendation first of all I absolutely
love those books I read them a few years
ago and I'm with you Dan I say the books
are significantly better than the movie
um some books for a high school students
wow that's I mean there's plenty of
things out there I'm a Harry Potter fan
myself and I think that you know that's
always a great thing to look into the
other thing is I know there's some
suggested reading lists out there I mean
some of our staff has provided some
suggested reading lists on that same
keep learning microsite that we shared
on the screen a moment ago and so I
would definitely take a look at some of
their suggestions because there's some
really wonderful people on staff who
have put some deep thought into what
they might suggest the other thing I
would say is that the important thing is
that your your reading and so I think
it's often underestimated that while
it's great that you know maybe you're
looking for some recommended books from
your teachers or from you know maybe our
staff but the important thing is that
you're reading so if there's something
to interest you and is really engaging
you whether that be you know a blog or a
book or you know maybe it's it's
something else I can't even think of
right now but as long as you're reading
what's really important is that you're
engaging yourself and more than you know
specifically any individual book Megan
we have a question on YouTube from
Elliott H it's actually for both of us
what what are our roles that Khan
Academy how long have we been here and
how it has Khan Academy changed during
your tenure so I'm on the marketing team
I lead the channel marketers and our
product marketing folks here and I've
been at Khan Academy for coming up on
two years and I you know I don't I don't
know if it's changed that much I just
feel like it's a team of extremely
passionate people
everyone's super motivated to provide
that free world-class education to
anyone anywhere and so I think you know
it's just been a pleasure coming to work
every single day with with the team
that's just just an incredible team
that's beautiful tan we like working
with you too and for those who don't
know Megan is actually my desk partner
so I said rights to Meghan I make if you
want to add a good week overview what
you what you do sure I would love to as
Dan mentioned he's on the marketing team
so I'm I work on our u.s. district
partnership team and I lead our u.s.
professional learning effort so what
that means is I work with teachers and
school districts all over the US and I
designed the teacher facing resources on
our site to better support teachers as
they use Khan Academy with students and
so I wasn't like I mentioned I was an
educator for nine years and now I get to
work with educators all over the US and
that's super exciting and I know part of
the question had been how long have I
been at Khan Academy I've been here a
little over two years and one thing I've
seen evolve is that Khan Academy always
cared deeply about teachers and students
and I think we've even tried to improve
that connection with teachers and
students and district administrators
even more so and we spend more time
connecting with them face-to-face now
than we did even before making we have a
really good question I think this is
really important for us to surface saw
on YouTube Daniel yang asks would you
make videos in different languages
Daniel lives in a non-english speaking
country and I always recommend Khan
Academy to my friends so in short yes
Megan do you want to provide a little
bit more info yeah I would love to
so Khan Academy is available in 50-plus
languages and we'd have an amazing team
of both employees and volunteers called
advocates who don't just translate the
videos but they localize that we have
experts who are creating similar videos
on the same content but have real local
meaningful cultural examples so it
doesn't just feel like we're voicing
over Sal's original videos but we're
making content that is important and
next to the students and teachers and
leaders in those particular countries
the other piece I would really highlight
here is that even within the u.s. we
find that schools really love having
their parents and their community
involved in their students learning and
so if you have a student who's learning
on Khan Academy they can change their
language from in school and out of
school so that parents and families and
communities can support their learners
and their cut in the language they are
most comfortable so maybe as as a parent
you didn't grow up in the u.s. system
you really want to support your child's
learning but you're most comfortable in
your own language you can adjust that at
home in your settings feature and so
your chair notes can learn with you at
home in the language and remotes
comfortable and then they can switch
that content back to English or whatever
their primary language they're learning
in at school and again all we have 50
plus languages it's on our website and
most of the images are available on our
app as well and still seeing a few of
those go pass right now and I can't
stress enough how grateful we are for
our international teams and for our
volunteers who are really the ones that
make a lot of this work happen yeah I
want to double down and just give a
shout out to those advocates because
they are an amazing you know team around
the world of folks who are really
volunteering their time to do this and
to Meghan's point they really are
localizing and taking the opportunity to
make that make things not only relevant
in a language perspective but in a
cultural perspective as well so it's
really important to highlight that there
there's a huge team who's doing that so
I will have a question from Scott yang
on Facebook hi Dan today at 1:30 p.m.
more than 40 badges were retired was
this an accident or do you intend to
make new badges so I can actually speak
to that so as some of you may or may not
already know we have a broad effort to
make changes we have a huge
infrastructure project in which we're
upgrading similar infrastructural
platforms and unfortunately part of that
we had to evaluate some product features
and things in terms
of what we will be porting over in our
new platform and what we can't and
badges we although we love badges and
I'm sure everyone really appreciates
them there's a lot of complexity in the
badges that we do have and so we did
make the decision to retire 40 badges as
mentioned and the team is working hard
to figure out once we pour over what are
the new motivation mechanics that we'll
be able to surface some of that might be
badges as some of it might not but yes
we will be replacing that at some point
just can't guarantee a time and what
that might look like just yet right we
have a great question on YouTube from
Irish non-air Shawn plays Khan Academy
do you work with teachers in Canada -
Megan we do not work directly in the
same way we work with school districts
in the US however we are really grateful
for input and feedback from teachers
across the globe including Canada of
course so I highly encourage you that if
you are a teacher in Canada or anyplace
in the world to provide us feedback on
what is and is not working for you or
for your students or for your school and
if you go to our Help Center there's
places to provide feedback or if enough
question believe recommend yep I think
we lost Megan for a second there well
sorry Megan you popped out for a second
if you don't want it yeah no problem let
me check my connection here is that in
here that's good all right let's try
that again
while we don't work directly with
teachers in Canada the way we do in the
US we do really value feedback from
teachers across the globe and if you
have questions or feedback or any great
ideas you'd love to share with us we are
so eager to get those and I highly
recommend visiting our Help Center where
you can provide that feedback or
questions or see community responses and
we do actually read those and take those
into consideration when we are
a king changes the product or improving
our teacher resources so please if you
have feedback we love to hear from you
and maybe we have a question on YouTube
from JR foster I think both of us can
answer this question what are some good
study habit tips for us to use during
these troubled times I think part of
what what we try to do at Kahn Academy
by providing the daily schedules as well
as the learning plan is to try to
provide some structure I think part of
it is building just good habits on a
daily basis now it doesn't have to be so
rigid that you feel like you're
struggling to do something so you know
alter it as you need but I think our
goal in doing that is really to create
kind of like a lightweight daily habit
so I've mentioned as Megan mentioned
earlier about reading it's not so much
important you know exactly what you read
as long as you're practicing reading and
I think that the same thing goes with
studying you know I don't think you have
to follow one prescription at least
personally as long as you're doing
something a little bit every day I would
echo that dan is that I know that
everyone out there learns differently
and that's part of what's so wonderful
about learning right people can approach
things differently and the same is true
with study habits just because it works
for one person doesn't mean it works for
someone else and I think leveraging the
schedules we provided to have some
structure but adapting that to what
works for you and that once you find
something that works really well I would
stick with it I wouldn't continue to
experiment over and over again like Dan
mentioned providing some structure that
works for you and sticking with it and
we know that it's really challenging and
don't be don't be too upset if you need
a day to just take a break for yourself
and then come back reinvigorated to work
harder and Megan we have another
personal question here Anoosh Bhagwan
asks how do you boost yourself when you
feel low at some points in life do you
want to tackle that first Megan and then
I'll chime in yeah I think that's a
tough question um I would say for me I'm
really grateful for such a phenomenal
support system first of all I would say
my husband has been a huge piece of my
life when I have felt down or made a
career change or things like that
and then taking some time to
reflect and I know Sal's really big on
meditation but taking that time to
reflect on some of the really great
things that you've worked hard
and been able to see those outcomes be
really powerful and then think about how
in your current situation you can use
those skills and learnings you've had in
the past to move yourself forward now so
I would I would say really good support
system and reflection to you know make
progress forward have been really
important for me yeah I would I would
echo the reflection piece I think for me
that that's really effective as well you
know looking at just not just reflecting
on myself but also just looking at
looking at the challenge and from
different perspectives like even now in
a global pandemic right I do think there
are silver linings one things that you
know this could be a very depressing
state and time I think for me one of the
things that really motivates me is you
know bhasayate behind the scenes here at
Khan Academy you know we work hard on a
daily basis but you can see the passion
that that your fellow coworkers have
during this time to really help people
who who need the help most right like
Sal himself Sal's been working 24/7 for
the last month and a half some of you
you know kind of see him here and there
but you know he's waking up at 5:00 a.m.
for calls on the East Coast for for some
media mention he's working at 6 6 7 8 s
8 o'clock at night to kind of draft the
daily learning schedules and I would say
that's indicative of almost everyone
here at Khan Academy you know aside from
the challenge of just dealing with the
crisis on a personal level everyone
feels super passionate about helping out
and I think that one has really in
particularly from me just been so
inspirational and it really can help
lift my spirits during this time all
right on YouTube we have a question from
arrived Jane what do I do when my brain
gets stressed in reading or math so I
think Megan you already alluded to a
little bit South Bend high on the
motivation on the meditation piece do
you want to speak to that a little bit
sure so Sal's been encouraging I think
all of us to take a moment to breathe
and meditate and maybe take a look at
some of the
you know guided meditations that he's
recommended or find a space just to take
a step back this can be a really you
know math or learning can be really
intimidating in a in a what we think of
as a normal experience and only
increases right now so don't don't be
too overwhelmed just take a step back
and give your mind an opportunity to
take a break right there's always time
to go back and work on that problem but
sitting there and repeatedly getting
frustrated with the same thing when
you're not you know making you know
having a productive struggle to move
forward take a step back maybe take a
moment to meditate or step and do
something else and then come back to the
work so that you're giving your brain a
chance to relax instead of just trying
to grind through it we have two
questions that actually this one's the
two questions one from Dave hand can on
YouTube I'm a teacher who'd you what do
you feel are some ways to motivate
students to actually do the work and
then similar from I meet new Walker on
Facebook how do I keep my fourth grader
motivated motivated to study with
schools not starting until the new
school year so I'm gonna take a moment
to plug our parent webinar that we'll be
giving this Wednesday on motivation so
we have a fabulous ambassador at Connor
Cory who's also a teacher and a parent
and Connor is going to be walking
through like the top tips for motivating
your your child during during this time
and that's gonna be on Wednesday from 3
p.m. Pacific at 6 p.m. Eastern and for
those of you who can't attend that
particular webinar will be posting
recording and sharing that out as we go
but in the meantime Megan do you have a
couple of tips for these for a meet end
Dave sure so a couple of things we've
been hearing from parents and teachers
are you know one taking the time to
learn with your child or student if you
you know are showing them maybe
something you're learning you know this
is an opportunity right I think that you
can learn anything spirit is really true
and in what you might be able to learn
alongside that has been really great
we've seen teachers get really
creative about how they're motivating
students and I think some of those can
easily be translated as a parent as well
so we've seen teachers do things like
leverage sidewalk chalk and visit homes
and put math problems on driveways and
then tapes have students take pictures
and send them back or mailing cards just
to say I'm thinking of you or you know
letting their child make a tik-tok video
with them in Halloween costumes so
things that are really you know unique
and and aren't necessarily high cost but
really able to encourage students to
learn something new and see a unique and
fun reward for doing so um believe maybe
it's time for us to do a couple of
social media mentions so so what sound
not here today one of the things that I
just want to call out from some of us
behind the scenes we are so appreciative
of all of the social media mentions and
comments and testimonials that we
receive from all of you and I think it's
worth sharing out because we get some
pretty amazing ones and then also if
please keep them coming I think they add
to kind of the inspiration and
motivation that you that the team has
when we get to see something amazing
from all of you so I'm Sal can you put
up a number eight a tweet and photo from
Jacob zip yep so Jacob says
supplementing Google classrooms with
Khan Academy the greatest value to be
derived here as mathematics science and
coding my daughter's chief interests
most parents at this time want kids to
get it all right but failure is a good
thing it aids the learning process so I
think that's a terrific comment Megan do
you want to speak a little bit to a
learning mindset because it really does
speak to building upon you know
challenges that you may have yeah I
think building a growth mindset is
something we all need to strive to
achieve and it's the idea that you know
Smart is not something you are but
something you can you know work towards
and and it's a process right learning is
a process and having the understanding
that failure doesn't failing does not
mean failure you always have the
opportunity to grow
and learn something new your brain is a
muscle and the more you use it the
stronger it gets
so taking those opportunities of
struggle and understanding that you
learn more by struggling and being able
to reach something and how great that is
when you finally reach that and we have
some great supporting content built in
collaboration with Hertz at Stanford sir
if you're new into that growth mindset
that learning mindset experience we have
some resources for both you know
elementary and middle school and for
high school and for teachers we have
lesson plans and guides that go along
with that content so we encourage you to
leverage pieces of that or all of that
as much as that's helpful to you and
then understand that all of us right
you're not born with the ability to
understand algebra right think about a
small child learning to walk right you
can't just stand up and do it all in one
day so being able to build your brain in
that same type of way and building those
skills over time and using failures as
opportunity to grow is just again
something we all really strive to work
with here at Khan Academy and we
encourage others to do as well we have a
question on Facebook from Tasha right
knocks my kids have been using Khan for
many years how do I get them to watch
instructional videos not done by Sal
they only want Sal kind of like when
Steve do I did love Steve on finishes
well I definitely sympathize here I
don't have a great answer for this maybe
maybe you do I think that's a tough one
we write we all get comfortable with
what we know and change is hard I think
even I am hearing other voices other
than cells sometimes you know throws me
for a loop but understanding that
there's so much value in diversity and
being able to hear other voices and see
other faces and so I think just keep
encouraging them and maybe if you can
find you know one other voice or one
other thing that interests them maybe if
the topic is interesting first and then
the voice narrating that or learning
alongside
students you know help support that but
I would definitely say Sal's voice is
absolutely wonderful obviously of course
we're huge fans here at Khan Academy but
being able to support diverse voices and
views is really important and I would
say even on our own site if you look at
some of our grammar content you'll hear
our colleague David or if you look at
some of our history content you'll hear
our colleague Kim so if even is starting
elsewhere on Khan Academy you look
around you'll hear some other voices
other than Sal yeah and I would also say
I mean the other thing is you know try
to introduce something new every day and
if your child doesn't like that or isn't
you know doesn't respond try it try a
different different instruction
instructor and hopefully they'll they'll
pick up on somebody else as well um so
Meghan we have a question specific Syed
it's the car sorry if I'm you know
mispronouncing Alam asks are you
planning to give your amazing teacher
training in Bihar India we actually have
an amazing makan India team so Megan you
wanna speak to that yes we have an
incredible team in India and they are
working on some incredible teacher
resources and scaling training to
schools in India and so my first
recommendation would be to check out the
Khan for educators India course that you
can view anywhere on our air india site
and so I would start there our
incredible team has put some together
some really thoughtful resources about
supporting teachers and learners in
India as we mentioned earlier we know
that it's important not just to
translate content but to localize to the
needs and culture and aspects of
individual you know countries and areas
and so I would a huge applause to my
teammates in India and to look at that
content and I would contact them if
there are specific trainings I know they
had things planned for in person but of
course at the pandemic a lot of that has
been put on pause but I would take a
look at the opportunities they have
there and it's really really wonderful
for teachers and learners in India
and then we have an SAT question on
YouTube from Rishi Gupta is college
board going to add more SAT dates so I
think you know um one thing I would like
to comment here is you know I think we
just all need to be a little bit patient
I think there's still a lot of unknowns
I know college I get a pleasure of
actually working with the college team
pretty closely I know that for the
upcoming dates they are they have
increased the number of seats pretty
significantly and so they're trying to
you know accommodate for this upcoming
situation I know they have the desire to
add more dates I'm not aware of any that
are coming up right away I think part of
the challenge is you know the the
uncertainty of when we're going to go
back to kind of a normal schedule and
then you know how do we kind of add
those dates around that so I don't I
don't have a great answer for that but
as soon as the College Board is able to
announce anything you know they'll send
it out and we'll also send out that
information to you as soon as we have
any of that okay here's a question on
YouTube from JR foster what made both of
you want to work at Khan Academy I can
answer that first Meghan and then you
know if you want to jump in so for
myself personally it was complete
serendipity so I've always been a fan of
Khan Academy from the first time I saw
Sal's TED talk way back in the day and
then I was kind of just browsing the job
boards when I saw Khan Academy's
position open and I fit everything that
that that I wanted to get out of out of
my professional life you know so as a
marketer I'm always interested in you
know the marketing work it's the
functional work itself but I always was
looking for something that was very
mission oriented for an organization and
I wanted to be a teacher growing up to
be honest that was one of the things
that I was really passionate about I was
a tutor in high school it was something
that really just gave me a lot of
motivation and energy and unfortunately
as a first generation you know immigrant
family my parents did not want me to
become a teacher unfortunately so I felt
like this was the best of both worlds
where I get to you know lose my
marketing chops but I get to do it and
work in a way that I still get to bring
education to kids and families all
around the world Meghan that's a really
wonderful Dan
yeah I was a high school science teacher
for nine years
and during that time I did use Khan
Academy a little bit with my students
but one thing that was always a
challenge for me as a teacher is that I
wanted to be able to reach more students
and Khan Academy was such a powerful
tool and Sal's you know approach to
learning was so powerful for me and my
students that it was as you mentioned
kind of serendipitous for me to find a
role that I was able to make the switch
from classroom teacher to working in
educational technology and now I feel
like I'm able to help more students
beyond the walls of my classroom and I
hope I hope that it feels that way to
teach your some learners sometimes and
I'm really grateful to work with such
incredibly passionate people like Dan
and the rest of our team who are just so
committed to our mission to provide a
free world-class education to anyone
anywhere and I'm so grateful for the
opportunity to be a piece of that so I
think we're at time Megan thanks for
joining me today I know it was a little
bit of last minute but I'm gonna have
tackle music nothing you'd and so thank
you audience for joining us Sal we'll be
back tomorrow with guest Mellody Hobson
from Ariel Investments and they'll be
covering kind of the economic impact of
this and I wanted to again thank you all
for joining if you like what you heard
here today if you like sales daily
homeroom please remember to like
subscribe follow and let your friends
families and colleagues know about this
session and about Khan Academy we have
active communities on Facebook Instagram
Twitter and YouTube and so thank you for
being a part of that and please share
share Khan Academy with other people and
with that goodbye
you